if you are an enterprise chances are you
have networking storage and compute on
multiple clouds and in your own
datacenter
how can you consistently secure and
operate existing apps develop and deploy
the new apps across those disparate
locations how can you get centralized
visibility and management of those
resources well that is why and those
exists
[Music]
welcome to anthos 101 as an enterprise
it is very common to have an existing
networking storage and compute on
multiple clouds and in your own data
centers on each of these platforms you
need to manage infrastructure let's say
you use containers on the clouds and
develop apps using services on Google
Cloud and EWS regardless of platform you
will need policy enforcement across your
IT footprint to manage these across
platforms you need monitoring and
logging systems and you need to
integrate that data into meaningful
categories like business data
operational data and alerts digging
further you might use operational data
and alerts to inform optimizations
automations and to set policies or s
ellos you might use business data to do
all those things and to deploy
third-party apps then to actually enact
the changes you decided on you need to
act on different specific parts of the
system that means digging into each tool
for policy enforcement securing services
orchestrating containers and managing
infrastructure management oh and don't
forget all of this work is in addition
to what it takes to develop and deploy
your own apps now consider repeating
this set of tasks and data across a
hybrid and multi cloud landscape it
becomes very very complex very quickly
your platform admins sres DevOps who are
responsible for security and efficiency
have manual cluster by cluster
management data collection and
information synthesis with this
complexity it's hard to stay current to
understand business implications and to
ensure compliance not to mention the
difficulty onboarding a new hire
Antos helps solve these challenges with
anthos you get a consistent way to
manage with similar infrastructure
management container management service
management and policy enforcement across
your platform as a result you gain
observability across your platforms in
one single place including business
information alerts and operational
information with this information you
might decide to optimize automate and
set policies or SLO s-- or might rely on
our machine learning models to make
automated suggestions you take those
recommendations or make your own
decisions and apply them to different
management layers simple right
not quite you may have different regions
that need different policies and also
have different development staging or
production environments that need
different permissions some parts of your
work may need more security that's where
it morons come in and wines are the way
to create logical sets of underlying
kubernetes clusters regardless of which
platform these clusters live on by
considering grouping and managing sets
of clusters as logical and minds you can
think about and work with your
applications at the right level of
detail for what you need to do be it
business insights over the entire system
setting for a dev environment or
troubleshooting data for the specific
cluster using advice each part of the
functional stack can take declarative
direction about configuration compliance
and more and those provides platform
administrators a single place to monitor
and manage their landscape including
policy control and marketplace access
this reduces person hours in management
enforcement discovery and communication
anthos also provides them now that the
Box structured view of their entire
system including services clusters and
more simplifying their view and
management so they can improve security
use resources more efficiently and
demonstrate measurable success and those
is also a platform to modernize
application development what because it
uses environs to enforce policies and
process
strikes away the cluster and container
management from the application teams
and those allows you to easily abstract
away infrastructure from application
teams by making it easy for them to
incorporate a wide variety of CI CD
solutions on top of environs allowing
you to view and manage your applications
at the right level of detail here are
the key components of anthos delivering
the capabilities we discussed and those
simplifies and provides a consistent
view across your company's landscape so
you can improve security use resources
more efficiently in a way faster and
demonstrate measurable success now
that's a pretty high-level overview of
anthos in the next video we will show
you how to get started with anthos on
google cloud until then like subscribe
and follow the links below to learn more
about anthos
[Music]
you
[Music]